the president's chief strategist Steve
Bannon has been dropped from his
controversial post on the National
Security Council a reorganization
removed Bannon from the nscs influential
principals committee the president was
strongly criticized for giving been in
that position in January mr. Trump's new
national security advisor general HR
McMaster led the changes now Bannon
denies reports he threatened to quit
over the move chip Reid is at the White
House chip good morning well good
morning the White House says Benin was
appointed to the principal's committee
to be a check on national former
National Security Advisor michael Flynn
they say now that he's gone there's no
reason for Bannon to remain on the NSC
this is just a natural evolution to to
ensure the National Security Council is
is is organized in a way that that that
best serves the president vice president
Mike Pence downplayed the
administration's second shake-up of the
National Security Council by removing
White House chief strategist Steve benen
from the principles committee and adding
back the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
and the Director of National
Intelligence the reorganization reverses
the changes approved by President Trump
eight days after his inauguration the
appointment mr. Bannon is something
which is a radical departure from any
National Security Council in history at
the time Valens NSC appointment stunned
some members of Congress and many
foreign policy experts including former
acting CIA director and CBS News senior
security contributor Michael Morell
having somebody like banning in the room
brings politics into a room where there
should be no politics Bennett served in
the Navy but as little foreign policy
experience he's best known for his
previous job as the head of Breitbart
news and ultra conservative and highly
controversial website I can run a little
hot on occasions a close confidant of
the president Bannon rarely speaks in
public but when he does he is a fierce
critic of the media and defender of mr.
Trump's nationalist agenda the
mainstream leader better understand
something all of those promises are
going to be implemented sources say the
removal of Bannon is just one sign of
the rise of a new
Center here at the White House led by
Jared Kushner and his wife the
president's daughter Ivanka Charlie chip
thanks